well for those of you who are coming in
now we represent the international
coalition of sites of conscience and
this is a network of now on nearly 250
different places of memory in 45
different countries that all share a
commitment to using the histories of
their sites to address the contemporary
issues that remain in their communities
so we work each of these sites works
very independently as we share this
common commitment in a common commitment
of helping each other succeed in each in
our own very different ways to use the
past and mobilize greater citizen
engagement in in making social change I
that the coalition was well I I was at
the lower he said or is that Laurie said
I'm not going to kindergarten but ago
before board the founding of the
coalition I was working on the Lower
East Side involved and to sort of
parallel and what I thought were
completely distinct areas one was a lot
of community organizing room and how the
issues and the other was in remembering
histories of neighborhood of places and
I began to sort of as a
way put some of those try to bring those
two strands together by creating
projects that invited people to remember
in histories of places in order and
exchange different perspectives and
generate different generations of the
histories of those places in order to
begin to address what had been lost
there who owns the place what needs to
be there now what needs are being met
would aren't being met and so all the
issues that were being dealt with in
this sphere of organizing around housing
issues and I found a number of museums
that were very interested picking up
that kind of project but and so did it
and then wound up doing similar things
in the different places around New York
and a couple of other cities in the
country but always it was sort of a
one-off interesting quirky little thing
and didn't change the kind of
fundamental institutional culture of the
museums and their commitment to
primarily preserving and collecting and
interpreting past and not necessary
from a kind of territorial authority
report a to the point of view but the
lower east side tenement museum was one
of the places they kept hiring me to do
little projects like that that seemed to
have a commitment to thinking about what
they were there for in a more
fundamental way and so they eventually I
started working there as vice president
of interpretation to develop exhibits
and programs that use the histories of
the families who lived in this 1863
tenement building to start raising
challenging questions about immigration
and housing and social welfare than a
road now and because that work was
although it seemed very obvious and
really not that out of the ordinary to
us it received very little support
either from the funding community from
even the museum colleagues and also even
for people who are from people for two
everybody thought that it was telling us
that it wasn't the proper role of a
museum to be using history in the
question we were asking you have classes
on photography's to be sort of you know
using history is that kind of a resource
but we were sure that there were other
places around the country and around the
world that shared that mission we're
doing that work so the president then
president attend museum and I reached
out in a very unscientific way across
the world to try and to ask whether any
other museums felt that it was their
core mission to use their histories to
open new kinds of dialogue and active
engagement in contemporary issues and
received in 1999 very few replies
actually but they were incredibly
interesting ones and they came from
Russia from Bangladesh from Czech
Republic from sites remembering the
slavery in the 18th century to
displacement and apartheid in the 1980s
and everything in between so that those
nine sites founded the international
coalition of sites of conscience which I
coordinated from the tenement museum
from that moment
till it became rude to the point of sort
of meeting its own organizational
identity or in 2006 and now
this is Chanku looking at the lunch
crowd I realized he was oh thank heaven
and I'm fix Gabriel and I have
absolutely no Frank ochberg by which is
what the best people have but my
background is actually am using media I
started out doing documentary you know
to bring to light all kinds of human
rights issues but also really as a tool
to get people community members engaged
in talking about whatever the issue was
neck started was working in domestic
violence in communities
in New York immigrant communities with
their lifestyle to a domestic violence
lack of resources etc so as a way to
reach people using phone and then other
types of media and put these sort of
issues on the agenda my background and
we'll just fell into the memory work as
we're in and I think you know in a way
it's a fascinating area for us because
really memory museums parts of culture
and immigration
and
has each other
okay I mean they've heard from us before
so do you want to do have something you
want to show the group all right okay
yes I don't know why I thought I was
like so for the lunch crowd maybe a
little repetition but that's always the
repetition is good because otherwise at
least for me if i don't hear something
five times than I forget so then what
I'd like to share with you is a little
bit about the coalition and sites with
conscience and the idea that really in
order to set up talking to about a new
project that we've just started to raise
public awareness about the century-long
history of the US Naval Station at
Guantanamo Bay and I'll tell you right
now I'm an agenda and that is to inspire
all of you to really conduct your own
oral history projects around this
particular story because it's something
that we feel is really needed and it's a
great opportunity provided a chance to
talk to people who are so experienced in
this area and so that
my final plug at the end we have two
great in terms of the working on this
project here we can talk to you about
their experience that's a way that we
like to come in but I'll talk about the
coalition in a slightly different way
that ordinarily do just because of this
group and try to articulate how each of
the sites has used oral testimony and
exchange of stories as a starting point
for mobilizing social movements and how
they particularly done that by tapping
the power of stories about place and
connections to place so let's give two
examples and we've talked a lot and
lunge about the argentinean and case but
so please add your own experience and
perspectives on this
getting a brief snapshot to provide one
example of how as I said how the oral
histories of place have really managed
to be the catalyst for very specific
policy changes in very major social
change movements were you know after the
sort of so-called transition is he in
Argentina but when the perpetrators of
the repression that occurred in the
military dictatorships I have been
granted amnesty there was one of the
sort of major kind of engines of the
public movement to try and achieve
justice for those people who had been
disappeared or detained was done you
know some historians would call it a
public memory or a public history
projects they're certainly these folks
wouldn't have but it was through
it was through a whole projects to claim
struggle for the visibility and
recognition of those people would didn't
disappear that was done in very public
spaces and varied through reclaiming of
different spaces from everything from
the plaza they my yo which you know most
people are most familiar with the
confidence of the President I you but
also by at in a later phase mapping and
marking former sites of torture and
attention that were spread all across
the city of Buenos Aires and across the
country in ordinary kinds of places
under everybody's noses and these in the
absence of any official inquiry
initially we're done through and
informal you know community-based oral
history or oral testimony collection and
at the time again you know the sort of
official collected in administrative
official way but nevertheless many of
these led to the uncovering I like the
focus is really hard to see isn't it
this is a this is an image of a
archaeological sites or excavation of a
detention center that had been covered
over by an overpass a sort of highway
that was placed over at that where
evidence of torture and detention was
found and even some human remains were
found so in this is just an example
found the absence of any kind of
official process or official oral
history project or testimony this kind
of informal oral history can lead to
actual uncovering of evidence that then
when the amnesty laws were overturned
and when prosecutions actually began
became the very basis of these legal
trials in an important body of legal
evidence that was then used to do many
other such excavations and really
discover important sites across the
country but the work of sites of
pensions don't stop there places like
mamoni yet though which is this
coalition of different human rights
groups that were involved in this work
all throughout the the years of struggle
are now looking to make these stories
relevant and useful to a new generation
that may not know that much about the
history
although it's so recent but they're
definitely feeling as legacies in
different ways through police brutality
through a kind of authoritarian culture
in schools and through a whole host of
other kind of unanswered questions about
their parentage and other legacies again
culture of torture and impunity so
they're using these simple oral
testimonies and it were taken so long
ago as the starting point for dialogue
around what kinds of expansions these
kids are seeing similar in their own in
their own environments today and what
they can do about it so this is an
example of again how these testimonies
and testimonies about place can fire
social movements at a whole variety of
stages of political change from you know
during periods of real repression to you
know making a major policy change to
sustaining that change through building
a culture of human rights among the new
generation another example is the
district 6 Museum in Cape Town many a
lot of Americans visited
familiar with that this was a
neighborhood in cape town that was razed
to the ground to make way for a white
zoning district and the members of this
community who lost their homes their
school's their businesses and were
scattered two townships all across the
outskirts of Cape Town but one group of
residents over one of the buildings have
not been destroyed this was a methodist
church that had been the site of major
anti-apartheid activism and covered the
floor of the church with a map of the
neighborhood have been destroyed when
invited people who had been displaced to
return to the only site they could
return to and write their memories of
what they have lost on this map and
women lost sort of emotionally in terms
of community in terms of culture but
also quite literally in terms of where
their house was and you know what what
they had lost and this experience of
coming together reconnecting with people
who had shared the same losses wound up
being at the real engine foundation for
the successful land reparations movement
that in which again some of the please
although most of these were more you
know
emotional testimony also began to
service real claims or who had lot who
had owned what property and who had lost
what property that became part of this
movement after the end of apartheid to
get people's land back who had been
destroyed and one of the courts that
actually granted the title to the land
back to those people live in this place
with how at what became the district's
as museum and was held right on the map
so another example of how you know
storytelling exchange of stories that
really two major social movement and
real viable change and it's again like
in the case of ammonia to get the story
in a conflict in the debate that still
continues because now the museum is
serving as a place for people to debate
what the new neighborhood should look
like there's now 24 units of housing and
have been built on the site but there's
still a lot of questions about who's
going to be able what does the
neighborhood going to look like who's
going to be able to live there and sort
of how are they going to capture the
community spirit that was lost and
recreated in this place so they're
continuing to be a center for that
debate and the stories their oral
history collection of what the neighbor
who was like in the past or the very
foundation
so these are two of the many of the
sites that came together around the
table in 10 years ago at that first
meeting to share experiences and decide
you know and talk about how we can work
together to tap the power of place in
the stories of place as a more
intentional tool for social change and
so they were two of the nine including
the ones in Russia tears in the world
Czech Republic and others that defines
this idea of a site of conscience and as
I talked to the folks at lunch about a
little bit they really this founding
group articulated three main pillars of
this or three main goals one was to tap
the power place to interpret history
through site and really explore what
does place have to teach us and how can
it move us in ways that other kinds of
media can accompany to have that the
second was to engage cluster programs
that
that foster dialogue on contemporary
issues that that our site histories of
our sights raised and the third was to
share opportunities for public
involvement in those issues but so there
were kind of these three general goals
were are interpreted me can you to be
interpreted very differently across
sites in many different contexts but
couldn't find us together with a common
vision they include in this crypt
dialogue piece is one of the
cornerstones of it and just to be clear
because I'm somebody and sorry I don't
know your name Robin Robin at lunch was
saying when she heard the lower east
side tenement museum was part of the
coalition at first was sort of like why
that doesn't make any sense and I
presume I don't know if this way me
because I think there's an immediate
association of sites of conscience
websites of atrocity or tragedy and this
you know the 10mm cm is war remembering
stories of daily life in daily struggle
and so how does that
what's the connection there but this is
a place that uses the oral histories in
particular but the individual stories of
families who lived in this one tenement
building to raise questions about the
enduring kind of unanswered questions
around immigration identity that are
still really volatile in the country
today so it's this using individual
stories to address contemporary issues
that's really the hallmark of sites of
conscience whatever the nature of their
history is so what we've seen is that
these oral histories in the service of
social change have made and kind of
helped tap the power of place in a
couple of different ways one in the case
of Argentina and also in district 6 it's
people's stories that have identified
places that have been wiped off the map
in some way and in some
cases they have been in the foundation
for legal evidence or of our legal cases
that have been built and in fact there
was a judge in Argentina that hadn't set
an interesting president where he built
and in most cases investigating
disappearances were built around events
and he actually tried and structured a
whole investigation around the place and
brought survivors of that place back to
it to give their testimonies and really
organize his whole investigation around
this one site and found that was enabled
him to uncover a lot more connections
and evidence that he than he was able to
do otherwise and these stories also help
when you stumble upon a place that's
partially destroyed or has been
neglected to help reimagine it be
created what that place was like which
is very important for understanding what
it is that we need to learn from it and
then most importantly for sites of
conscience and they try to use people's
stories to tap into what the questions
are that the place closes for us today
and really use those stories as a
catalyst for
questions so these are the ways that i
think these sites are really trying to
use these histories so that was all just
to give you a little bit of example of
how we've worked and to date and what
these sites are about what are some of
the issues that they wrestled it because
all of this is now being brought to bear
on a new project that we're working on
to tap the power and the lessons of a
new place to really open new kinds of
debate immobilized action we're talking
a little bit about this at lunch but
again that the sites and the coalition
have tremendous amounts of experience
helping people to recognize places that
have been wiped off the map by there
because they have literally been
destroyed or because they've been
repressed or sort of hidden deliberately
hidden from view and this is the kind of
crowning example of that so our next
place to tackle this the US Naval
Station with one kind of obey a lot of
people and the place to look even though
the physical location of it is something
that many people are not very connected
to but it is located at eastern tip of
Cuba and it has been a really
fundamental although invisible part of
American politics and Paul
they not just in the last 10 years but
the work about a century before that so
since 1903 and I think these layers of
barbed wire relates to illustrate that
one time ago has been used and reused to
detain a whole host of different types
of people who have been perceived to be
threats to the United States and it has
enclosed many times before only to be
reopened for a different purpose and in
all of these openings and closings and
makes about openings and closings
throughout all this it has come to
represent a wide range of experiences
for hundreds of thousands of different
people who have spent time there some
have spent time there as a workplace for
some it's been a place to call home
brothers has been a beacon of freedom
and of course for others it's been a
life of confinement so all of these
buried stories and this long history has
really led us to ask you know when this
Guantanamo been closed before and when
has it been reopened who and what did we
forget in this process and why is it
that we should remember
so that's kind of what's that what's
binding us together and we were talking
a little bit about ownership this
contest of our ownership and sites
earlier at lunch and the question of
whose flag flies at Guantanamo has
really been a major source of
controversy from the moment that was
even hosted here out of the
spanish-american war in 1898 and I'm
going to go in a little bit to some
history here just because unlike a lot
of other stories I at least really very
little about this and I think we just
need to lay the groundwork of them what
happened in order to think about why
it's important to remember but in 1903
the u.s. signed a lease with Cuba coming
out of the war that maintained Cuba's
total sovereignty over this territory
meaning that that the bay you know this
part that they would remain human soil
but it gave the u.s. total jurisdiction
which meant that the u.s. could act
there as it wanted with no interference
from Cuba or anyone else so that tiny
sort of ambiguous ownership I've created
a really sort of a no man's land really
ambiguous territory where neither us nor
human law clearly applied and it sounds
like a kind of arcane legal question but
that is what we've been fighting about
and what that means is basically what
we've been fighting about ever since and
meanwhile in generations of people have
been caught in the middle of that
contradiction
and their stories are what provide I
think critical insight was to the very
peculiar nature of this place why it
came to be used as it did in the last
ten years and our kind of intimate
relationship with it that it isn't just
recently that this came to be a part of
us but so for that reason I think these
stories help us to imagine what our
teacher could be there and get us more
involved in what it should be there so
I'll give just really brief snapshots of
some of the I think over 60 although
every day Beck's finds something new and
our team find something new the stories
that we've discovered that I hope could
be the starting point for oral histories
that nem you do but taking a case of Pat
Duffy and her dad to start with that
Debbie's dad was one of thousands and
thousands of Cubans who came to work on
the base every day in the 1940s and 50s
and they passed freely back and forth
that through small gate you know from
the from you outside the base onto the
base but after the Cuban Revolution and
workers became Tsar suspect or potential
threats to national security potential
kind of communist spies that was kind of
an undercurrent that was changing the
culture of the base
and so base officials gave workers a
very difficult choice and that was he
can either keep their jobs but in order
to do so they had to live out the rest
of their lives on the base neither us
nor Cuban citizens because it was a sort
of stateless place and so Pat Duffy was
five years old in 1960 when her father
left home made that choice and left home
for the base leaving Pat and her mom on
the other side of a massive really
barricaded new fence that divided very
sharply in the base from Cuba but three
years later when I was eight she and her
mother put on their best dresses and
scaled the fence to join her father and
they actually took tore their clothes on
the barbed wire and Pat has kept the
special dress that she wore on that day
and it could be the first artifact and
fiscal in this collection and and sort
of made it to join their father to this
kind of utopian residential community
and she her memory of the base is that
she loved growing up here she became
homecoming queen there's the high school
on the base everyone played together she
remembers across race and other line
and in her narrative it was only on a
class trip to Washington DC the sort of
other America that she faced any
feelings of exclusion per US citizen
classmates you know sailed through
immigration to spine whereas she was
sort of question in a way that was very
disturbing to her because her papers
weren't in order or for whatever reason
so her you know she experienced this is
his exceptional place and have shielded
from the dangerous in the realities of
both the u.s. and Cuba and so that when
her own daughter Priscilla was born in
1933 1983 she insisted that Priscilla
should also grow up on the base but in
the 1990s as you know the threat of
communism society which was very sort of
threat that made Pat's sheltered life
possible a new threat began appeared
that that transform went on over one
more time and that was a huge influx of
refugees answered almost simultaneously
from Haiti and Cuba and they were
actually on their way US mainland and
makeshift books but both sort of in
succession george bush senior and then
later bill clinton feared that this
massive influx of people would cause too
great as their political uproar in the
u.s. to be handled using existing
immigration
so rather than allowing and these folks
to enter the US as anyone else would be
able to particularly asylum seekers they
entered I to the refugees at sea
contrary to our laws the time and
brought them to this in-between
character territory of Guantanamo as a
space where they could deal with them as
a political threat rather than using the
existing laws that would have applied
how they made it to the mainland in the
u.s. so then there was this long period
of kind of deciding their fate in this
no-man's land I'm so one story as you
wanna Jean who's one of the thousands of
refugees is housed in these tents
massive tent cities that were set up as
a makeshift tent cities on the island
she was banned from entry to the US for
being HIV positive but was also had a
legitimate asylum case so she couldn't
return to Haiti as her life was in
danger she didn't want to return to
Haiti as her life is in danger and she
became a spokesperson and for hundreds
of others who are in her situation who
were kind of not allowed into the US
because their HIV status and not
because their Asylum status and she
actually went on a hunger strike they
got the attention lawyers and media and
ultimately than she and others like her
that you could say were credited for the
closing of one time what everybody
thought was the closing at a time in
1993 a US judge closed what he called
its HIV prison camps you know saying
that this you know is euphemistically
referred to as a kind of humanitarian
operation but you know I call it nothing
more than HIV prison can't leave ordered
the closure of the camps and the other
times celebrated in a sense of closing a
painful chapter in America's immigration
history but you know almost immediately
after it was all kind of happening at
the same time there were still 30
thousand human refugees detained you
know it's a whole different trajectory
on the site you know in their own tent
cities that works as a side by side for
a time and how yeah that's what if they
do with the Haitians when they close
camp well they are in mixed you tell you
a little bit more a lot of were vast
majority were repatriated and so it was
actually a small number by the time it
got to the point of closing there was a
very small number and we're still there
because though this closing was really
going to be an end to a practice
of using guantanamo as this place to
kind of park people who we didn't want
to deal with with her under our existing
laws but ultimately it had to be settled
but with a compromise that gave those
few haitians the opportunity to seek
asylum and sort of rented their
particular that appeals but did not
change that did not prohibit the use of
Guantanamo where the or change the
status of one time so that was a big
disappointment and I'm sure I go I'd
nurses has money talks about that in
their collection so that's again with
all of these sounds like kind of
technical legal points but then it all
comes down to what why these individual
people were set it ripped kind of in
this territory and why this can continue
to happen so Pablo Rodriguez it's
somebody else who
be a fantastic oral history he's now at
medical school at Duke great for but he
was eight lend his family left Cuba on a
boat thinking they you know we could
like many others before them we're going
to be able to make it to Miami but again
this was a sort of suddenly seen as
exceptional political threat because
that he was part of a massive migration
of human refugees and so his boat was
internet addadd seeing he was brought to
one animal in 1994 so he has these
memories about you know and half way
these innocent childhood memories but
mixed with a real sense of difficulty
and despair and he was there for for a
year and a half at least I think before
being able to make it to Miami and as I
said now
he's in medical school but you know he
was not one of the last people to be
ultimately released and the last person
was named margarita Sanchez and she was
boarded a plane on january thirty first
nineteen ninety-six and and this was
also celebrated as a closing of one time
ago complete with a big public ceremony
with a concert by at Moya Stefan she was
you can see like the media of on media
here camera that I mean she was like the
poster child for this end of Guantanamo
but there was a refugee journalist who
had been released a little bit the court
noted we must remember that the cans of
Guantanamo are closing but this is a
painful story that's not over yet and
that was you know not that long ago Cuba
well that was a bit one at this is like
another big legal battle that was
another quandary for the administration
of you know Castro sort of you know as
effective jab at knowing to go back not
kindergarten but Carter in the 19 80 and
81 I'm kasra had done something similar
where he had a kind of sudden like a
couple of days of amnesty where anybody
could be Cuba and his head you know it
involved was massive integration of
humans that landed in Miami and it
became one of the political debacles of
Carters career when Clinton so then
Carta Castro do this again in I guess 93
and when when he heard of this so
everybody 30,000 Cubans set off from
elsewhere you know in their boats and
when Clinton heard of this he said I
can't be I can't have another Carter on
my hands so what I'm going to do is stop
them at sea and bring them to Guantanamo
and we'll kind of deal over this that
will deal with it somehow so that I'm
protecting myself as a political
question it's not a legal question I
have every right to do this but
nevertheless of course with the strong
lobbying of cuban-americans he had also
a lot of pressure not to repatriate the
humans that were in Guantanamo because
of what would happen to them if they
tried to return to Cuba so that's partly
why this took so long to resolve and he
wound up just sort of letting people and
it drips and drabs so it's not to have
this like huge influx that that that had
sort of in his mind cause so much
trouble prepared so
I don't know whether there was I think
there was some number that were
repatriated but it was a small
eventually as he had to change he
changes of changing US immigration
policy towards Cuba instituting what has
become known as wet foot dry foot and
all the Cubans a quantum well roughly a
little more than half were about to come
into the u.s. okay so that's a much
bigger number but part of this is like
buying time to have to sort of port to
the political I mean it's like putting
people in an invisible place and letting
the news cycles kind of run their course
so that so that the kind of volatility
of what he saw as the political
challenge of this would kind of be able
to
so then we come to the histories I think
you're much more familiar with just to
let you know their relationship you know
camp x-ray which man can remember was
one of the first prisons that the first
Afghani combatants where they were
incarcerated in 2001 was built for the
Haitian refugees so it was a building
that was built you know these structures
these physical structures on Guantanamo
you know we're built at different
moments for different threats and are
being used and reused and open and
reopened and of x-ray is now abandoned
and this is only five years after its
active use and the sort of amount of
decay is already showing how quickly we
forget about these places and how
quickly their memory is erased so you
know we're not trying to draw
equivalencies between any of these
experiences there are totally different
political situations totally different
life experiences but the war on terror
and the use of one turn among the war on
terror did not have rise in the vacuum
and so you know even if the last
prisoners are transferred elsewhere it's
going to remain with us probably long
time and I think what's interesting for
us as we've started to bring people
together around remembering this history
and raising awareness about it is that
it's been attracting people who have
wildly different political perspectives
on the issues today
and we all believe that the current
understanding and people's her
decision-making that involvement is
really impoverished by their lack of
knowledge about what has come before so
it's been work you know try to get
people remembering the history has been
a way well we've been interesting
together some really interesting people
to the table so just briefly to show
tell you what we are hoping to do in
terms of our goals for the project and
the short term is really informing the
debate over whether and how to close
Gitmo and in the long term it's hoping
to provide a forum for coming to terms
with what has been incredibly not just
difficult in divisive history but a very
traumatic set of events for individuals
and for the country but mostly is to try
to inspire new public involvement and
what's going to happen there next
there's new construction that's
happening on this site as we speak
there's a multi-million dollar contract
out for building new refugee facilities
so you know the trains already left the
station on whatever the next life of
Guantanamo is going to be and I think
the assumption is that everybody's going
to forget and make it
we just want to prevent that so we
talked a little bit about at lunch about
the fact that we're using the site as a
teaching tool but primarily our media
are going to be off the site we're not
trying to build a museum on the base
right now although there is one on the
base and one run by the US Navy and one
right outside the base run by the
municipality of Guantanamo City telling
very different stories of course that
we're trying to map and promote those
people who are doing work to capture the
stories of the last 10 years there's
great work out there on that but our
focus is trying to highlight the stories
that have come before that to provide
perspective on where we are now the
group that came together to launch this
included sites of conscience from around
the world that have had experience
dealing with very remote and hidden
places a lot of them work sites of
detention and torture and and as well as
people from military personnel
historians human rights activists and
all of them believe that this needs to
be an international project this is not
just for us audience it needs to have
the perspective of all the different
peoples and governments that were
involved in this site and also to
connect this site to use the place as a
powerful symbol in teaching tool go to
people understand that it's connected to
a whole set of other similar places
around the world so what we're what
we've done for the last year and this is
our great team can tell you a lot more
about this is any x we've done Norma's
amount of mapping of existing resources
identifying more than 800 images more
than 60 individual stories as well as
some artifacts and video footage and
other material that's kind of out there
but nobody said sort of put together in
this way and we're now developing a web
platform to make all this available and
trying to focus our the role of the
coalition it's kind of facilitator in
two ways one is to host as many
stakeholder meetings as possible among
people who have had different
experiences of the site in caucus groups
but then also across different
experiences and then also to facilitate
new work on this so whether it's trying
to encourage you to do like your next
project oral histories of Guantanamo
survivors or it's putting out calls for
artists responses or storing you know
academic historians to do more research
we have people who have
saying I want to do new school curricula
on this so we're trying to use our
position and funding that we can get to
Commission work and make this kind of a
collective 2 point 0 type of project so
that we are helping to work with Mary
Marshall and her team as well as some
other folks at Columbia and collaborate
on a sort of showcase in the spring that
we hope you all Spring of 2011 but
mainly I just wanted to encourage you to
think about doing your next projects on
this history in some way we have two
interns here and that internships
available in the fall maybe yes I don't
know queer folk but so if you're
interested in getting involved track to
fix or or the team about their
experience things